bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors la turquie a annoncé que
son navire de recherche déployés en
méditerranée orientale avait regagné la
côte turque est ce que selon vous c'est
une première étape vers le dialogue que
réclame la grèce oui bonsoir bâbord dont
je ne pense pas je pense tout ça en
donne une certaine manipulation de turc
pour laisser croire que elle va être
plus calme dans ses approches mais
personnellement je ne crois pas compte
tenu de ce qui se passe depuis des mois
sinon des années que la turquie veulent
calmer le jeu pour l'instant nous sommes
dans des rapports de force qui ne sont
pas militaire proprement dit mais des
rapports de force de façade
donc il faut savoir un petit peu ce qui
va se passer par la suite avec art hogan
mais ce qu'il a dit vis-à-vis du
président macron contre à l'évidence qui
n'a pas l'intention de céder sur un
certain nombre de points
alors on va revenir sur ses déclarations
les avances à la grèce a annoncé en
début de journée l'achat d'avions de
combat français 18 rafale
quel regard est ce que vous portez sur
cette démarche franco grec pris à trois
dimensions
la première vous venez d'évoquer encore
grecque nous avons un partenariat
stratégique depuis 2020 avec la grèce il
est honoré
nous sommes dans la belle union
européenne il est tout à fait normal que
les habits et premier ou deuxième point
pour l'industrie d'armement nul ne peut
regretter que 18 rafale de plus soit a
chuté à dassault qui est une bonne chose
pour notre industrie d'armement il faut
dire clairement
troisième point surtout c'est un message
très fort lancé par la grèce à la
turquie pour dire si vous venez vivre et
nous nous narguer
nous prenons les moyens pour nous
défendre notre souveraineté dix-huit
avions rafale ce n'est pas négligeable
c'est un achat rapide il faut bien sûr
former des pilotes mais cela montre que
face à la turquie personne n'a
l'intention au moins dans cette zone de
baisser les bras alors revoir à présent
sur les propos très virulents du
président du président turc erdogan qui
s'en est donc pris à nommément à
emmanuel
chrome lui demandant de ne pas lui
chercher querelle comment est-ce que les
tons sourds peuvent s'apaiser entre la
france et la turquie membres toutes les
deux en rappel de l'otan je ne vois pas
trop comment ça peut s'arranger à la
date d'aujourd'hui
erdogan a un agenda personnel qui est la
réélection de 2023
il sait qu'il est en difficulté en
politique intérieure
le fait de gesticuler sur la scène
internationale lui donne un certain
pouvoir d' influence sur son électorat
jusqu'à présent je ne vois pas pourquoi
il change d'attitude
on le voit en libye on le voit en
méditerranée orientale
on le voit en syrie ce n'est pas
l'attitude d'un président je dirais
pacifique
maintenant vis-à-vis de l'otan
personnellement je considère que la
turquie n'a jamais joué vraiment un rôle
important dans l'otan qu'il est
regrettable que le traité de l'otan
n'est pas prévu l'exclusion de l'un ses
membres et il est tout à fait dommage
que la turquie est encore un poste au
sein de l'otan mais ça d'avis très
personnelle de la france alors pourquoi
ce que paris et s'y impliquer dans cette
crise qui ce jour méditerranée orientale
je suis pensa concours de circonstances
d'abord on joue des évoqué la notion d'
union européenne il y as train article
de notre traité qui dit on doit porter
assistance aussi l'un des membres et est
agressé d'une manière ou d'une autre
c'est le cas avec la grèce ensuite il ne
faut pas négliger la question de la
libye nous sommes dans une position un
petit peu ambigu soutenant d'un côté sa
rage que la turquie soutient parce que
l'onu a décidé de lui donner une
représentativité
je prends bien de sa rage et d'autre
part nous ne voulons pas que l'islamisme
radical se développe en libye et c'est
pour ça que par moments nous avons sans
aucun doute soutenu le maréchal à tard
voilà donc je crois qu'on a des enjeux
comment dire antagonistes et puis
peut-être un dernier point n'oublions
pas que le président noir dogan est
affaire musulmans que la politique
peut-être de la france où tu es de la
laïcité envers l'islamisme radical
sinon l'islam politique est comme très
clair et peut-être que le président ado
gan qui vient de donner des passeports à
des membres du hamas
faut quand même pas l'oublier des frères
musulmans considérés par terroriste par
un certain nombre d'états c'est quelque
chose qui perturbe un peu je dirais les
relations entre la turquie et la france
merci beaucoup pour votre analyse
françois chavance y est générale expert
en géopolitique